you
when I was a college professor my
favorite course was teaching beginning
guitar and every year every every
semester there would be a couple
students from the general college who
would be in the class there would be a
couple openings or 15 guitars so we'd
have 15 students and a couple openings
mostly music education music therapy
majors and but there were two lucky
winners of the lottery and there they
were and I'd always at always tell
everyone we're going to be we're going
to be accompanying ourselves with our
guitars as we sing and at this juncture
the two hands from the general college
would go up and their faces would be sad
and I knew what to expect and I and I
said yes what's the problem they said
well mr. Stewart we're going to have to
drop the course and I said well why and
I knew what they were going to say and
they said well I can't sing and I would
say well well who told you that and they
wouldn't there was never a moment's
hesitation they would say uh my aunt
Susie when I was six or my second grade
teacher mrs. Johnston it was always some
somewhere around six or seven that they
had been cast out of Eden and they were
told you don't belong here
you don't belong so when they saw this
opportunity to take the guitar in for a
college course they thought there's a
way back in there's a way back into the
into the garden there and then here
they're finding out no no the gates are
closed to me and I would say I would I
would look at them at these faces they
were so sure of where they you know they
were going to walk out yet again and I
said well I'm I'm happy to report that
the original diagnosis was incorrect and
none of these students were able to
prove their unworthiness to me they I
think the most stubborn lasted two weeks
before he found out that he had a voice
I've got a Johnny Appleseed thing I
believe that the word musician is too
often used to discourage people from
participating in their birthright as
sound makers we are all sound ventures
I'm just going to remind you all of your
birth rights and show you some
instruments that I've created along the
way to help stubborn cases shall we say
recognize their birth rights there was a
rule in my household no musical
instruments at the dinner table the rule
had to be had to be enforced regularly
we had sound makers all over the place
so I grew up making lots of sound and I
never got over it and when I got to be
when I got to be older and and I and I
had studied years I studied the cello
and I studied the guitar and I'd studied
the piano and I'd done a lot of singing
but I always wanted to make I wanted to
make a sound on a wind instrument and so
I'm on up on a tour I was fortunate
enough to be playing in Twelfth Night a
wonderful production of at Lincoln
Center the summer of 98 and Paul Simon
was in the audience opening night and he
he had a million questions and the last
one was can I get your phone number I
gave it to him he called and I've been
playing with him ever since and that's
been a joy the first tour on a pop tour
you have two options you have you have
some free time so you can either work on
a new drug habit or you can have a
project my project involved vibrating
columns of air I've soon discovered that
every tube was a didgeridoo and when I
was emerging from the seventh or eighth
dumpster on our seventh or eighth date
my to be bride said mark here you've got
a job what what are you doing what he
jumping in dumpsters I said well for me
it's patriotic behavior I'm recycling
and finding things and she said well
there's something more to it and then a
couple of weeks later I walked out and
there was a butter knife in the in the
gutter and right away you know how your
brain just leaps you don't have any
control it leaps I designed this a thumb
piano made from found objects in that
instant I've seen a butter knife every
day in my life it wasn't until it was
garbage that my brain I went home that
night I said sweetie I can tell you I
like the way my brain works
when I'm looking at garbage when you
play it backwards
it's the hermaphrodite of musical
instruments the Shallah do I only have 5
minutes and 7 seconds to Shelly Moe was
the French Baroque clarinet no keys just
holes this is the shall I do why cuz
it's a shell mo and it's a didgeridoo so
it's the shala do I carry this around I
had this whole idea about companion
instruments I carry this everywhere in
New York there are lots of private
moments in public space I found them all
this is American electricity or 60
cycles lights slightly sharp b-flat this
is European 50 cycles a G I'm equipped
to deal with any kind of buzz anywhere
in the world with this horn yeah so
shall I do it so many people asked about
it I started carrying recipe cards I
brought some tonight but maybe another
time but if you really want one the
front has a little schematic in the back
has all the instructions how to make it
anyone can play this you come out of the
womb going all set to use your mouth in
the way I'm a guitar player lots of fun
the slide whistle organ why why does it
sound so good I said to myself why why
is this so lovely it's because you've
never heard three flutes play in perfect
rhythmic unison before it's a simple
little thing but there it is and it's
delightful
these instruments don't inherit a system
of order people who play these tend to
get right to the finger-painting of
sound people get right to it I had that
I had the bug I designed this I didn't
have a laptop can we see if we got
something that that's a bobby pin here's
the long side
here's the we side nail file this
instrument is different every day oh by
the way that all the little pieces are
taped their holes every every piece of
tape on the cello do is a hole open up
another set of holes on another day have
another horn do something else where the
holes where your fingers are can it play
a C major scale said my esteemed
colleague you know I think the C major
scale has enough friends already okay we
I think we gotta get right to the the
jam session here so okay you have you
have drinks stirs right take your drink
stir
everyone got it you got these little
things okay v you're about to experience
real hi-fi for the first time some of
you have done it before okay it's called
bone conduction
now these drinks tours I got them this
morning there's one side that's kind of
flat and one that's kind of tall take
the flat side and you're gonna bite it
like this stick make one side a little
longer than the other fight it yeah nice
bite yeah okay now you're going to take
your thumbs don't do it I'm going to
tell you you're going to take your
thumbs you're going to plug your ears
not yet because you want to hear me plug
your ears and then you're going to use
your pinkies to play the thing okay
sorry
okay you're the only one that can hear
you now two knit two knit get a boomed
dink dink Capone King yeah alright so
how many people are here does someone
know how many people how many 350 we're
going to play 350 duets right now and
every one of you is going to hear the
duet only you you're all going to hear
me but only you are going to hear you
this is private music there's public
music there's private music private
music together okay we have 39 seconds
here we go B to D blah so pleasure to be
with you tonight
you